okay so in this video we're going to
discuss the functioning of the
respiratory system so let's get started
so when we talk about the respiratory
system we're talking about the organs
that are responsible for the exchange of
gases gases such as oxygen and carbon
dioxide now the main organs would be the
lungs and inside of the lungs thousands
and thousands of clusters of air sacs
known as the alveoli so here's a little
zoomed in diagram here of one of those
air sacs of an alveolus and notice it
has a tiny capillary just on the outside
of it well what happens is oxygen will
diffuse into the capillary into the
bloodstream while that's happening
carbon dioxide diffuses out carbon
dioxide is removed from the capillary
into the alveoli and so when a red blood
cell comes along here comes a red blood
cell the red blood cell will pick up
some of the oxygen and that oxygen is
then distributed through your body
because of the actions of your
circulatory system you know your heart
is pumping the the blood and the blood
cells all throughout your body so this
is how the gas is Akash is carbon
dioxide and oxygen are exchanged at the
alveoli we're gonna go into this in a
little more detail in a moment well next
I want to focus on the path that air
will travel when it's inhaled so we're
gonna start with the nasal cavity or the
nose so sorry mouth breathers but we're
gonna focus on the nasal cavity well
first of all this process is going to
begin when you look at the muscle
underneath our two lungs called the
diaphragm when this muscle contracts it
actually pulls air and oxygen into our
lungs and so the diaphragm plays a
really important process in the pathway
in which air will then enter our system
so what we're gonna have is oxygen being
pulled into the nasal cavity you know
the nasal cavity also does a great job
in just warming
the air in case it's really dry and
really cold that could be a problem for
people with various breathing conditions
such as asthma or bronchitis so next we
have the back of the throat known as the
pharynx now this is also part of the
digestive system but for today again
we're focusing on the respiratory system
so the oxygen is now moved to the back
of the throat the pharynx and my
animation the pharynx will actually
connect to the blue tube that you see in
the picture called the trachea and the
trachea will then take air into the two
lungs and so one thing I want to mention
the pharynx is lined with cells that
possess little tiny microscopic hairs on
them called cilia and so you add the
mucous membranes in the cilia and you
know allergens such as pollen grains or
dust can get trapped in this sticky
coating the cilia and the mucous
membranes and prevent the irritant from
ever reaching your respiratory system in
your lung so it's a great way to filter
some of the air that we breathe so now
we're gonna make our way down the
trachea or also called the windpipe and
so here we have the oxygen moving down
the blue tube known as the trachea and
this is the passage that will lead
towards both of your lungs now we have
our left lung and our right lung again
this is from the orientation of the
person so even it looks like it's
backwards by when you look at this
screen here the left lung appears on the
right the right lung appears on the left
but this is from the orientation of the
person you know one thing I want to
mention before we move on is how does
the oxygen go down the trachea and not
the other tube at the back of your
throat called the esophagus which is
part of your digestive system well we
have a little flap of tissue right here
called the epiglottis whenever we
swallow food or drink this flap of
tissue the epiglottis seals off the
trachea so there for food and drink are
then directed down the esophagus you
know every now and then
we you know we've swallowed food or
drink and it actually goes down our
trachea and that starts the gag reflex
the coughing and the gagging and
eventually week off up and and spit up
whatever accidentally and today
accidentally went down the wrong tube
and one thing to also mention about the
trachea like the pharynx the trachea is
also lined with cilia and to help trap
and catch any irritants and allergens
and pollen grains that could be in the
air that could cause air eret that can
irritate one's ability to breathe and
eventually as the air moves down the
trachea there's there's a fork in them
in the road we have two pathways one
leads into one bronchi leads into the
right lung and one bronchi leads into
the left lung and so that's what the
bronchi are these the two dividing
branches the direct air into each of the
two lungs and so oxygen you know splits
off some of the oxygen goes to the left
bronchi some of the oxygen goes to the
right bronchi and ultimately the bronchi
then subdivide into thousands and
thousands and thousands of smaller
branches scattered and spread throughout
your lungs and these are these thousands
of smaller branches are what are called
the bronchioles and so as oxygen moves
through these branches the bronchioles
and you can see they're the true
importance of this I hope is to really
increase the amount of surface area when
when we are breathing to increase the
surface area of gas exchange
this helps to allow for the most
absorption of oxygen with every single
breath having all the oxygen branch off
into these thousands and thousands of
different tubes increases our ability to
get oxygen from the from the air that we
breathe and then as we come to the tips
of the bronchioles there are these
clustered air sacs if you kind of use
your imagination it kind of looks like a
cluster of grapes and these are called
the alveoli and this is where really the
magic of the respiratory system
and so these clustered air sacs are
located at the tips are at the ends of
the thousands and thousands of
bronchioles so you can imagine there are
thousands and thousands of alveoli in
your lungs as well okay so what we're
gonna do next is we're gonna zoom on in
and take a closer look at the alveoli
and when we do we can see that the
alveoli are wrapped a rev little tiny
blood capillaries wrapped around them
this is really important because the
oxygen that is inhaled will enter these
capillaries and then your heart will
pump and carry the oxygen away all
throughout your body so let's add here
comes some oxygen let's add some oxygen
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
zoom on into this one single alveolus
right here and here's all the oxygen
that just entered and as we said a
moment as we said a moment ago there's a
blood capillary wrapped around the the
alveoli and so notice the color change
the blue area of the capillary
represents an area that's oxygen-poor
and the red represents an area that's
oxygen-rich well how does this change
how does the blood go from oxygen poor
to oxygen rich well if we remember what
diffusion is the movement of molecules
from an area of high to low
concentration right now there's a high
concentration of oxygen inside the
alveoli and there's a low concentration
of oxygen in the capillaries and so
oxygen will simply diffuse from a high
concentration to a low concentration and
then it's picked up by a red blood cell
and so let's see that again oxygen
diffuses in and is picked up by a red
blood cell and carried away let's see
that again oxygen diffuses in and is
picked up by a red blood cell and
carried away now of course in reality
it's a big flood of oxygen that's
diffusing into the capillary while
that's happening carbon dioxide is being
really
and is diffusing out of the capillary
and into the alveoli their carbon
dioxide is diffusing from a high
concentration which is in the capillary
to a low concentration which is in the
alveoli and so this is what we meant
earlier when I said the exchange of gas
carbon dioxide is exchanged for oxygen
so now that we traced the path that air
and oxygen travels through the
respiratory system pause the video pause
the video right now and try to identify
the parts that you see in the diagram
I'm gonna go over the answers in three
two one
okay so Part A what did you think
if you thought Part A oh those are the
bronchi then you were correct Part B
Part B is simply just the person's right
lung again even though it looks like
it's on the left side of your computer
screen from the perspective of the
person this would be the right side of
their body therefore letter c letter c
is the nasal cavity find letter D letter
D are the thousands of branches called
the bronchioles
what about letter e letter E is the
muscle underneath our our two lungs
called the diaphragm and this helps to
push open the ribs and draw air into our
system how about letter F letter F would
be the left lung again even though it's
on the right side of your screen from
the perspective of the person this would
be their left lung how about letter G
what's letter G the letter G is the
trachea also called the windpipe and
then how about letter H letter H is the
pharynx the back of a throat called the
pharynx and then finally letter AI
letter I when you zoom on in you see
those clusters that would be the alveoli
and so if you're in my biology class you
know pause the video and take this
practice quiz and see how you do I'd be
happy to check your answers before
school or after school one day everybody
else thanks for watching I hope you
found this helpful